hey you yes you i'd like to tell you
about an exciting opportunity okay for
real though something dawned on me last
year that i really want to share with
you all because it really radically
changed something about how i perceive
the flow arts drex here from drexfactor
poi sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i want to talk
with you a bit about why i think there's
a very big reason why we should get more
people creating flow arts content before
we dive in i just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard lane machinski and
becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
from my work and my mission
so there is a really really important
statistic that i came across last year
that was kind of a keanu reeves whoa
moment for me
and it has to do with the size of the
community and who the community is made
up of for reasons i won't go into right
now i set down a goal of reaching 35 000
subscribers on instagram happy to say i
actually made that goal last week but
that wasn't the woe moment
it was what that number told me in the
last quarter of 2021 i was climbing that
hill from 34 000 subs to 35 000 subs and
i happened to drop into poi chat one day
stick with me here you all know how many
people there are in poi chat
as i'm writing this script the number is
33 000. as of right now i have 35 000
subs and there are 33 000 in poi chat
in other words my audience on instagram
is bigger than the entirety of poi chat
and my youtube as of this writing i met
over 88 000 subs more than double the
number of people in poi chat so what am
i saying here that i'm more important or
influential than poi chat no not at all
poi chat itself is not the point i think
a lot of people who are on poi chat see
it as representative of the bigger
community
it is after all the single largest flow
arts group on facebook this is the place
you want to go to get noticed to connect
with other people or to put your finger
on the pulse of the poi world and yet
it's a place that has fewer participants
than tune in for my videos on youtube
and instagram
and i'm not even the most popular poi
spinner on either platform poi and the
flow arts are much bigger than we think
they are think of it this way there is a
venn diagram of people who follow my
work online and people that are in poi
chat
those two groups do overlap but they
clearly can't do so completely
that suggests that there's a broader
world of poi spinners in general that
has to be larger than both poi chat as
well as the audiences for my channels
and that's not all this may come as a
shock to some of you out there
but i am not everyone's cup of tea
in fact near as i can tell there are
people out there that passionately
loathe both me and the content that i
create
and they also spend poi so whose content
do they watch
there's a bunch of candidates out there
but i have a suggestion
why not yours think that's such a
strange suggestion i don't i know a lot
of people who don't get into creating
content because they think there's
nothing left to be done there's no
shortage of tutorials out there or
influential poi spinners who've
cultivated massive followings
you're getting started years after
they've developed their brands so what
else is there for you to do believe it
or not i used to ask myself the same
question nick woolsey started his
channel before i did so i avoided making
my own tutorials for years because i
kind of reasoned that nicks were
so good what exactly did i have to
contribute to the conversation and then
i ran into a problem
after i quit my traditional job i
started booking workshop dates in other
cities and without a doubt the most
common question i got about them was do
you know how to teach beginners seems
silly in retrospect right
and it surely did to me at the time too
but then one such person put together
some pieces for me and i quickly
realized that i'd created a branding
problem for myself at the time everyone
knew me for my tech blog a weekly video
series in which i showed off the most
recent tricks i was playing with or
ideas that i'd come up with
it definitely established my bonafides
as a mover and shaker in the tech poi
scene but the vast majority of it also
went straight over a lot of people's
heads so with this knowledge i undertook
making my first ever tutorials first
with a series on learning how to do real
turns and then later on how to do poi
flowers and several one-off tutorials on
things like weaves and the like and they
took off
they became the most popular content on
my channel wait hold up how's that
possible nick already had all these
resources out there
why would someone bother to learn from
me different people learn different ways
and a lot of people learn best from the
people that they feel like they have a
personal connection to
my tutorials became popular because my
style of teaching was what some people
were looking for it connected deeply
with them sometimes you watch a tutorial
from one creator and it doesn't quite
connect the dots then you watch another
one from a different creator and boom
there was the perfect description or
demonstration that made it click and you
know what there are tons of people out
there that don't learn well from either
my videos or from nick's videos there
are plenty of people out there who've
never found the person that they connect
with so what if you're that person for
them i think that i connected with
people who like to intellectualize the
things that they do they like to
understand the theory behind why a thing
works the way it does and they want
detailed visuals of the thing being
performed but i've totally had people
come into my classes who did not connect
with my teaching style at all for a
variety of reasons and my guess is that
there are a lot of them out there again
there are 33 000 people in poi chat and
not all of them follow me
i have more than a hundred thousand
subscribers across different platforms
so we're really only seeing the tip of
the iceberg here
there are huge potential audiences out
there for new creators if you create the
content that they're looking for and
will connect with people are out there
waiting for new people to connect with i
swear they are and these numbers
brought home to me just how many of them
there must be out there i don't think we
have a good way right now to measure how
big in total the poi spinning or broader
flow arts world is
maybe you can help us figure that out or
even better help us grow it
if you're interested in being a part of
something larger there's never been a
better time than now i would imagine
that a bunch of you out there have
actually thought about starting a
channel and have been inspired by me in
the same way that i was inspired by nick
so what's keeping you from doing it what
are your doubts what are your questions
what do you need help with leave me a
comment and let me know and maybe i can
help
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
if so please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible if it were not for the
wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arch to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you are you
interested in creating content but don't
really know where to start i have a
playlist of videos i've done to
hopefully inspire yourself and others
that i'll link to down in the
description or up on screen if you're
watching on youtube make sure to get
outside to flow today and i'll see you
with a new video on wednesday thanks so
much for watching and have a good one
peace